m
elle va mieux
la peau blocs loges costumes à bordeaux
ce n'est pas al ahmar a mené cette gaffe
à toi t'es où vas pas mal un coup
d'arrêt je perds mon père vous a pas mal
ans ou trois dans mon bureau
ma tête je veux pas vous entendre
permanence est ce que vous savez
pourquoi vous êtes dans mon bureau parce
que vous êtes en colère
oui je suis en colère mais savez vous
pourquoi vous n'avez pas à régler vos
comptes de cette manière en créant dans
la cour et c'est là qu'on veut que sur
nous oui on peut rien leur dire oui
c'est vrai ça elle sans forêt et je peux
savoir ce que vous leur avez dit on
faisait des copines c'est vrai non ce ne
sont pas des compliments
ce ne sont pas des objets des objets
enfin vous êtes déjà demandé ce que ça
fait d'être regardée est abordé de cette
manière on puisque c'est comme ça vous
serez coller jusqu'à 18 heures
ça vous laissera le temps de réfléchir
un peu à tous âges seria maire de guémar
oh mon dieu je suis vraiment tension de
l'amphi partance à lui aussi sa mère
dégâts possibles sa dette accouchement
bon servette a pas encore réveillés on
va passer ça votre g qu'on ait des
fiches on va s'amuser
toi moi les autres jusqu'à tout gentil
là tu vas pas commencer à couler sur mon
site et c'est très bien ce que tu veux
alors tant qu'à prendre ça comme un
compliment c'est tout temps quand on
regarde trop tard del moro à celle là tu
comptes pmi arrêt de maths et je peux
basse paul mac os obligé c'est quoi tu
mama toi
ce soit non voilà tranquille
ça va
je filtre pour eux
bonjour
quelque chose
harcelé de faire soumettre sans répit à
des petites attaques empathie nom
féminin capacité de s'identifier à
autrui dans ce qu'il ressent